President Biden is getting upstaged the
big guy will finally be hitting the
campaign Trail this week after blowing
it off for over a month and letting
Democrats like Gavin Newsom do all the
heavy lifting the California governor
has been relentlessly attacking
Republicans and proposing big liberal
ideas like a new 28th Amendment on guns
Newsome has already shown America that
he's comfortable at the White House we
all remember his confidence sleeves
rolled up appearance while Joe was out
of town and now Newsome is getting his
message out to a larger Audience by
sitting down with Sean Hannity
do you think he's cognitively strong
enough to be president conversations all
the time yes and I'll tell you what you
do I'm dead serious about that I've
Congress I've talked to him when he's
been overseas I've been an Air Force One
Marine one I've been in the limo with
him I've spent time with him okay but he
never answered my question directly how
many times is your phone ping a day
people saying you need to get in this
race because they agree with me that
he's not up to the job I would say I see
where you're going with that I'm asking
no I and I'm not answering
hmm well you can catch the full
interview with Gavin Newsom airing
tonight on Hannity at 9 00 PM Eastern
meanwhile Biden has a new excuse to stay
out of the spotlight a root canal the
president canceling all events today and
letting Kamala take the reins while he
was getting the dental procedure White
House reporters seem to have a lot of
questions about it
is there any more information you can
give on Hawaii the root canal like is
not good at brushing his teeth or does
he need to floss better or anything wow
are you talking to the millions of
Americans across the country you can ask
them that question too a little research
this morning I mean look I am certainly
uh not uh a dentist by any means so I
cannot speak to uh what leads to a root
canal
unbelievable
um instead of doing the root canal Jesse
I want to talk about why Gavin Newsom is
not forthright in answering whether or
not he wants to run for president I mean
well here's what I would say if I I was
asked by Hannity I'd say well you know
Sean not as many times as my phone pings
from people telling me I'm crazy to sit
down with you
late in the moment deflect and you get
away with it but he can't even do that
that was a binder level answer that was
a Dodge they might have to yank him as a
surrogate like they did Eric Adams
because you got to be quick on your feet
and he's not Sean's gonna rat tat tat
he's on radio three hours a day you
gotta have something a little bit better
than that and in terms of Biden's
cognition I've talked to people that
have been in briefings with the
president they say he has good days they
say he has bad days on the bad days he's
not paying attention at all talk to
people who've been negotiating with the
president they say he comes in and he
reads from a script and if you interrupt
him he gets totally flabbergasted and
then his staff has to save him if he's
not falling he's falling asleep he's not
falling asleep he's hiding if he's not
hiding he's getting an emergency root
canal we are going to get to the root
causes of that that one of these days
he's got 31 approval judge he's not
debating he's not campaigning and he's
going to arrest his opponent now he's
only going to do that because he can get
away with it it's like the media can
make or break you they made fetterman a
star they can break Joe Biden with a
question about the bribe the Border
inflation it doesn't matter now he
reminds me Newsom of the quarterback you
know when the starting quarterback takes
a big shot and he kind of gets up from
the turf and he's like and then you see
the backup quarterback on the sideline
like throws the helmet on and starts
getting loose that's Gavin Newsom
because the coach might make a change
any day
you know Harold there's got to be a
reason I mean he sat down with Hannity
for the obvious obvious exposure it
would give him he's running around to
Red States trashing DeSantis why can't
he give an answer as to I mean doesn't
he want to run for president good to be
back around the table I don't know what
what he wants to do I do know I thought
it was smart to sit down with Sean uh
this is to Jesse's point this is not
where you thought he might give his
first interview uh and certainly there
is a belief that intention in terms of
the his philosophy about politics and
and Sean's I thought one of the more
telling moments and moments we need more
in politics when Sean asked him about
the homelessness issue which we'll see
more uh you'll see more of it tonight
and he owned it Gavin talked about
Governor Newsom talked about the
challenges they're having there and he
talked about housing costs but he said
there are things we should be doing
better and could be doing better all
right let's take a look we need moments
our viewers know what we're talking
about
this state has not made progress in the
last two decades as it relates to
homelessness why because housing costs
are too high are regulatory thickets are
too problematic localism has been two
impactful meaning people locally are
pushing back against new housing starts
and construction I've been here four
years I can't make up for the fact in
2005 we had an historic number of
homeless under Republican right now
there's 171 thousand that's crazy okay
it's graceful and all right I'll compare
to Florida again 26 000 of course okay
same weather similar State I mean I've
lived in both Dynamics are very
different that said we own this Sean I'm
not I'm not here
so I thought I just thought that was
when you think about where we are in
politics and we need less smallness and
less pettiness because we certainly have
an abundance of that I hope that what
may come from that is perhaps the
governor able to get back and work with
state legislators and local leaders
including the San Francisco mayor about
things that can be done since the
governor is a former San Francisco mayor
as well but look you asked a broader
question I'm not sure what he will do I
thought the interview served him well as
governor and if he does decide to do
something whether it's next year or a
few years down the line uh that was the
first time I've seen him in that kind of
setting in a while I've seen him those
clips of him talking about you know as
he's out talking about things he's doing
in California but in a tough interview
uh you got to give him Kudos there and
how he performed all right Greg Harold
was talking about less small lesson
pettiness so I'll go to you but what
about the issue that you know speaking
of pettiness and smallness that Newsome
goes around the country and trashes
DeSantis well that's also again it's to
raise this profile right he's you know
he's shown up like if you're like a
lower level villain on Batman you try to
get into Batman's World by making fun of
him and doing stuff like that he's kind
of Gavin's kind of like the Riddler he's
not the Joker he's the Riddler but he
wants to be the Joker so what he's got
to do is he's got to get into he's got
to get under Bruce Wayne's skin as
opposed to Batman's skin which is Donald
Trump he this is a waiting game on both
sides right uh you know newsom's
hovering around Joe like a vultures over
a slow dying tortoise and Death Valley
just circling maybe he'll make it we
don't know but they'll keep Circle
meanwhile there's like what 10 people in
the waiting room at the on the
Republican side because they're also
waiting for that moment that Trump
either drops out or something so there's
this weird thing going on but 80 percent
of the Democrats this is an interesting
thing 80 of the Democrats or 80 of
everybody thinks their candidate should
debate most of them were Democrats
that's pretty interesting but it doesn't
seem like they care and this is a just a
speculative thing it doesn't look like
they care
he has the slowest lowest like uh
polling since the Big Bang his mental
decline is obvious I compared him to a
paper straw and a milkshake it's worse
than that
um he's in big trouble I think he's in
big trouble but he doesn't act like it
and that when with an attitude like that
it's almost like it's a foregone does he
just believe he's gonna win
that he doesn't have to worry uh that
the election the nomination is in the
bag uh it's like he's getting a Lifetime
Achievement Award what does that mean
that that raises a lot of suspicions I'm
sorry but it does if you just know you
don't have to worry about a thing
what's that telling you all right Dana
I'm not following please it's red Dana
the whole thing is rigged Dana he can't
manage one state how could he manage all
of these states oh Gavin Newsom yeah
it's a good line well you know Joe Biden
had never managed anything and it's just
kind of showing there you have it oh I
mean there there is that I do think that
Governors at least they've had some
level of responsibility whereas if
you're coming trying to go from the
Senate directly into the White House
it's much more difficult I I think that
the White House is probably getting very
frustrated with Gavin Newsom because
nothing says that
nothing exposes a basement level
Campaign like somebody like Evan Newsom
being willing to go on Sean Hannity's
program I am wondering at what point in
my life I will stop being so naive I was
like oh that's that's I love the
interview that was really great and then
William logginess pointed out that oh
there might be a reason Gavin newsom's
going on I thought oh my gosh how did I
miss that yes of course he's wanting to
figure out a way because he's dealing
with two contingencies he either is
planning for one of two things that
Biden doesn't ultimately either get he's
going to get the nomination but is it is
he unable to serve is that the choice or
does it look like the Democrats are
doing so poorly we're going to talk we
can talk about Kamala Harris later
um if they're doing so poorly then
that's another thing the other thing the
White House is frustrated with I imagine
is that they keep trying to elevate
Trump they want to run against Trump
Gavin Newsom keeps elevating DeSantis
and trying to point out that DeSantis is
the one that they should be more afraid
of so the White House I think has a big
problem on their hands yeah okay I went
and kill Mead I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now